the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is that it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
well it's a pleasure to welcome uh Dr
Dan Hooper from fermilab uh in in
Chicagoland area to the into the
impossible podcast which is a podcast as
part of the Arthur C Clarke Center for
human imagination and some exciting news
we were just recently picked up for
distribution using the UC University
California TV network so this video may
appear eventually on a UC Channel near
you which has a huge audience of
basically millions of people and it's of
course available to the whole internet
so that covers a few dozen people I'm
sure but it's a pleasure to welcome Dan
uh Dan has a new book called at the edge
of time he's on a book tour right now uh
it happens to find him in the same time
zone as us but not back to the same
state and I thought we would uh begin
with uh with a little introduction to
you know who you are what you do how you
spend your time and the kind of work
that you do exceptionally so in terms of
bringing science and education to the
public so Dan tell us about yourself how
did you how'd you get here what's your
world line from that outfit to today
well it's a long and open-ended question
but um some uh particle physicist turned
astrophysicist I never thought I'd be an
astrophysicist but that kind of happened
by accident I split my time between
fermilab and the University of Chicago
and I work on things like dark matter
and cosmic rays and neutrinos and things
like this
um in terms of Outreach and education
stuff like that
um one of my favorite parts of my job is
the teaching and I really enjoy being in
the classroom I kind of take every
opportunity I can to do that
um this book the new book is my third
book so um I've been doing this for a
while but I'm particularly excited about
this one I've spent more time with this
one than I spent with the others and um
I I think um maybe there's a a good way
to to reach a wide audience about the
sort of work that you and I do and
bringing the awe and wonder of the
universe to many people as we can I'm
curious how you got started in particle
physics and then sounds like you kind of
accidentally were led by your curiosity
imagination things that we care about
we'll discuss how did you get interested
in in just physics and science generally
speaking uh when you were a kid what's
your what was that like well it didn't
happen when I was a kid I know most of
most of our colleagues they'll have a
story about you know in kindergarten
they decided they wanted to be this
specific subfield the scientists that
they are now and all these things I have
nothing like that um I grew up in the
very rural Minnesota
not only did I not think I wanted to be
a scientist I don't think I had any idea
what it meant to be a scientist I just
didn't know it encounters or experience
with that
um I took normal science classes in
junior high and high school but I didn't
find them very exciting
um you know physics was rolling things
down inclined planes it wasn't you know
the cool stuff
and then uh I go to college not for
science so I intend to be a music
student and
um I got kind of disillusioned with that
tried a bunch of other things and
eventually wound up taking a modern
physics class
and uh falling in love with it so in
that one quarter I learned about
relativity a little bit about it anyway
I learned a little bit about quantum
mechanics and these were the two most
interesting things I'd ever heard about
in my life I knew that from the very
beginning there and uh I suddenly became
a good student because I cared for the
first time and I worked hard and
aggressively and I just kept looking at
these sorts of cool counterintuitive
science uh physics things from as many
angles as I could next thing you know
I'm in grad school trying to study
particle physics and I like you said I
just kind of my curiosity and and and
Imagination keep pulling me towards the
cosmos the next thing you know I'm an
astrophysicist and a cosmologist along
with a particles
and uh curious curious as to whether you
uh completely disconnected Your Love of
music do you still uh play music I have
friends in Chicago that are in you know
choruses and it's all sorts of
orchestras and there's no shortage of of
aesthetic activities for you in
Chicagoland so tell me did you uh were
you playing an instrument do you still
playing in German
so I mean I I play quite a few
instruments but the one that I really
play as guitar I taught myself to play
when I was 15 or so and uh got pretty
good
um been in bands throughout my whole
life
um other than a couple of months here
and there
um for the last 10 years I played in a
Soul band in Chicago called the
congregation if you're up in the Chicago
area then check us out or for that
matter just use the internet there's
that too yeah so yeah music's always
been a big part of my life but it's a
very different part of my life than
science
um I go out of my way not to think
scientifically about music I don't want
to know how it works or why it works I
want to feel it not think it and I enjoy
using that other part of my brain yeah
that's I always forget you know which
brain side I use or not I know it's only
you know I aspire to someday use 10 of
my brain like they see people do and not
knowing much about music uh you know the
only instrument I I play is the iPhone
but the mutual friend uh you know Sean
Carroll is a big Jazz Aficionado or
Mutual friendly Alexander is a
professional jazz musician and there you
know there is a mark kaminkowski another
theory so I don't know what it is a
theorist and and jazz music or Soul
music but uh seems to be is Mark a
musician Mark is not a musician as far
as I know but he's a great Aficionado of
jazz okay all right and um yeah so so it
there definitely seems to be something I
mean getting back Pythagoras uh the
great ancient Greeks and the stoics et
cetera love the they ruminate on the
relationship between physics and music
or math and music I I feel like a lot of
times it's a little overblown and and
like you said you know sometimes you
just want to listen to the music and not
think about the music so uh but it's
it's often been said uh there's a book
called range it's a new book where they
do a study of course on you know um
people that have achieved Great Heights
and and all different Endeavors ranging
from Arts and Science to you know
politics Etc and they they look at what
were the Hobbies of these men and women
what do they do and they find the most
successful you know a very strong
correlation between success in a field
whether that's you know my least
favorite thing the Nobel Prize or you
know Pulitzer prizes or you know uh
conductors and major Symphonies that
they all have
um hobbies and they have enthusiasms
that extend beyond that and uh the
social scientists wrote this book range
I'm blanking on his name might be
eisenstein I forget anyway he claims
that you know this using the kind of
full connect Dome of your brain is what
really caught the breadth of knowledge
is what allows you to see new
connections so obviously you're not like
thinking about that when you're uh you
know writing down the new dark matter
candidate or appraising a result from
the experimental Community but uh it's
certainly not lost on me how many people
have these kinds of passions
um that at first glance seem you know
orthogonal but but perhaps you know had
this interest for you stimulated it
well I think there's another important
thing at least in my experience which is
having I have a very obsessive
personality when I get into something I
get really into something which helps me
to get good at it so
um for the same reason that when I was
teaching myself guitar I would play for
six or eight hours a day most days
um that later translated into me doing
an awful lot of physics and I think both
things helped me to get good at that
that uh that that Freight helped me get
good at both of those things and then so
one thing that we look at in terms of
the artistic connection between you know
science and and the greater human
imagination is of course science fiction
we are affiliated and bear the name of
Sir Arthur C Clarke who was obviously
not only a first-rate science fiction
author but he contributed to a lot of
you know Innovative Concepts and
technology and in science and you know
for us the kind of gateway drug for many
of us with science fiction and
introduction to great writers in the
past and you know uh your book at the
edge of time now available from
Princeton University press I believe
right
um they uh you you have an impressive
roster of people that uh that have given
you blurbs on the back of your book
ranging from John Carroll to my friend
and yours Katie Freeze and uh whiteson
and of course myself and what I said in
uh in this book and I really believe and
I'm grateful I had a chance to read it I
said where Weinberg Stephen weinberg's
first three minutes left off Hooper's at
the Edge of Time picks up a riveting
tour of modern cosmology told by one of
its savviest guys Hooper's book takes us
on a journey from our universe's
formally inscrutable past mesmerizing
possible scenarios in its far future
fascinating story that is to be savored
and I kind of um I do see your book as
kind of picking up where weinberg's book
left off which is you know obviously
High Praise but I think it's um Weinberg
is an outstanding writer and a
communicator one of my favorites yeah
and so um I'm curious as to like what
were your influences my you know as I
say Weinberg you know clearly is in this
tradition that you're in what were the
influences that you know in your life
and may not only be scientific it might
be science fiction or other can you tell
us about you know who were the mentors
and people that you look to in the past
so I I'm uh you know eager reader I read
a ton ton and most of it's non-fiction
but you know quite a bit of fiction
slips in there too
um some of my favorite books in my
college years were popular physics books
um back then I was a really big fan of
Paul Davies for example he wrote a lot
of books on these things and John
Griffin
um people like Michio Kaku and and
um you know uh Liam Letterman I read all
these things back then Hawking uh Kip
Thorne
um I think I read Weinberg a bit later
that was a little bit later
um these days
um there are a lot of our colleagues
writing really good Popular Science
and and I read a lot of this a lot of
our colleagues don't read Popular
Science because they think they know all
the science that's contained in it and I
read it though for how it's communicated
because I think we can become better
communicators by uh by by seeing how
it's done well
um I enjoyed your book for example I
enjoy uh you know Sean Carroll you
mentioned I enjoy his writing a great
deal
um I just read some stuff from uh gen 11
that I think is really first-rate really
exceptional work
um I have uh Joe Dunkley's cosmology
book on my shelf I haven't quite read it
yet but it's uh it's right up there it's
on my on my very short to-do list
um but I really like reading nonfiction
that isn't physics oriented whether that
be biology stuff or economics or other
social science
um history I find to be written in a
really different format so I don't know
that I learn a lot about writing from
that but uh social science and and not
necessarily physical science I really
find uh helps my writing to to uh to uh
get deep into that stuff so the the
aspect of your writing and and the story
it's sort of you know it's sort of
journalistic and that you you know
you're able to weave together a story
that really does take us back
um you know to before uh what was what
was previously hidden I think in the in
the writings there really wasn't a book
that filled in these gaps with enough
technical uh you know apologies to My
Vegan friend but you know meat on the
bone satisfy you know like I often will
read science
um Popular Science trade books as
they're called because I can blow
through them really quickly because you
know I'm reading Sean's book now or
listening to Sean's book I'm going to
interview him for the podcast in a
couple weeks and um yeah I'm just like
Fast Forward I mean I love Sean and he's
a great writer but you know I I know
what the Double Split experiment is and
he's I like and he gave me great advice
you know when I was writing my book I'm
like you know do I have the energy to
regurgitate you know the Big Bang
nucleosynthesis argument you know and
like he already did it you know do I
have anything he said he told me great
advice he's like you you can tell it the
way that you want to tell it in other
words you can tell it through your eyes
not that I get to pick my own facts and
say you know that hydrogen formed you
know a billion years ago instead of you
know about 13 billion years ago but I
get to tell the the highlight the
important aspects Through My Lens which
was covered by Dost obviously and I I
wanted you know originally to call my
book A Brief History of dust but I don't
think that would be really really
possible but what spoke to me is that
you you're bringing a really Advanced
subjects you know kind of uh you know
the notion of bearing on a symmetry and
readers you know I want readers to read
the book because these are very Advanced
topics but the the advanced topics are
like the analog to what we want to teach
versus what we have to teach so you
mentioned like the incline plane so you
and I have how to teach the incline
plane it's part of you know how we get
our salary right but on the other hand
we love to teach our brilliant young
students who are taking cosmology or
particle physics because that's close to
the boundary of what we ourselves are
learning about and there's no better way
or teaching about there's no better way
to learn something than to teach it and
and you know that all too well and what
I love about your book is that you're
not you don't shy away from things like
these really you know I mean compared to
the price of you know sliced bread it's
not that important on a daily basis but
you know the baryony Symmetry the origin
of these mysterious things that may
indicate very weighty things the arrow
of time the composition of the universe
the Deep you know future of the universe
so I wondered if you could not you know
I hate it when authors are asked you
know can you summarize your entire book
so that nobody has to buy the book yeah
I want people to read this book because
I think it's it was a really fast read
for me and it wasn't because I knew
everything in it uh quite the contrary
it was very interesting to hear you know
from a perspective of somebody who
wasn't isn't a native astrophysicist as
you're saying
um but you know what struck you about
astrophysics that caused you to make a
pivot you know in Silicon Valley speak
into you know becoming not only
um you know a Top Flight uh performer or
practitioner of of astrophysics but but
to really be able to break it down to
the public what what drove you in that
direction
so as a particle physicist there are
really kind of two routes you can take
as a particle theorist I should say
you can take the what we call the top
down Road where you maybe study
something like string theory and try to
deduce How the Universe must work from
some sort of Grand principle
and usually this involves a lot of
mathematics I mean all of our work
involves a lot of mathematics but this
is even more mathematics
um and very rarely does this stuff
directly connect with experiments I
learned pretty early in grad school
that's not what I wanted to do I just I
I like um I like knowing that in three
years there's gonna be experiment that
tells me if this paper I'm writing is
right right or wrong you know and
usually it's wrong okay but um I like I
like knowing how we're going to uh get
closer to the right answer and in string
theory it's not obvious that we know
that
on the other hand you can do particle
physics from the bottom up where you say
okay well here's a bunch of things we've
measured some things we don't understand
about those measurements are the
following
let's try to work out theories or models
or something that can explain those
problems and figure out what experiments
we will do or should do to find out if
that's right that's much more my uh you
know kind of Mo that's that that suits
my personality quite well
but when I was a grad student you know
Lepp had just finished up left was uh
the electropositron collider at CERN at
the time they were just finishing and
the large pattern collider wasn't going
to turn on for quite a long time
so there wasn't a lot of collider
physics that was going to happen in the
short interim
so I start thinking about other ways to
study particles
for particular ways to study particle
physics using the cosmos so my first
project along these lines was talking
about how dark matter particles might
get captured in the sun where they would
annihilate with each other to interact
and destroy each other converting
themselves into neutrinos and then we
could detect those neutrinos with big uh
telescopes I was thinking of the Ice
Cube experiments at that time
and uh I got pretty deep into that I
learned a lot and got excited about it
and then another Dark Matter project and
then another Dark Matter project and
then some neutrino astronomy projects
and then some gamma ray telescope
projects and pretty soon I looked around
within to my surprise I'd become a
master
it was not my plan at all
um but given the time and place I it was
the right move to do it and now I spend
maybe half my time just thinking about
the early Universe which is a great
thing to be doing right now
um with stage three and stage four CMB
experiments like and and gravitational
waves and and and all these very
exciting things going on telling us
about the first fraction of a second
after the big bang
um I can't help but to be pulled in that
direction
can you explain to the audience why
should it be that these fundamental
particles the smallest things that exist
you know how they could have any
relationship to the entire universe
well I mean the short answer is the
universe is made of Elementary particles
and um if we specifically are talking
about the the early universe as you go
backwards in time the universe was
hotter and and denser and the Dynamics
of hot dense things are described by
Elementary particles so if we go to the
core of the Sun we find a bunch of
protons and electrons and a plasma
they're going uh so those protons are
undergoing nuclear fusion and I mean
these are laws of physics the following
that you wouldn't know about if you
hadn't done uh particle physics kind of
experiments and if you go to even hotter
environments it's not just things like
protons and electrons but things like
quarks and gluons the kind of particles
we study at the Large Hadron Collider in
fact the kind of collisions we study
between protons is a large pattern
collider tell us a great deal about what
the universe was like a trillionth of a
second after the big bang when it was
full of all the particles that we study
of the large and the way we know about
the laws of physics that dictated those
early moments of our universe's history
we uh basically know that because we
carry out experiments in particle
accelerator environments like large
right yeah the universe as an
accelerator you brought that up or you
you mentioned that and I think that's
something that surprises folks because
um you know it may only be possible to
build an accelerator uh at most on Earth
that has the circumference of the earth
uh but then after that you have to start
thinking other sorts of designs uh but
then as you say looking back into the
early Universe uh it was essentially a
giant particle collider the fact that
these wispy most minuscule particles in
the case of neutrinos that you mentioned
earlier that they could perhaps have
something to do with
um with the structure of the entire
Cosmos which is the largest thing we can
possibly ever observe
um uh and so I think that that is a
fascinating thing I often you know a lot
of your book talks about dark matter and
it's not surprising for a particle
astrophysicist
um what as a human being you know just
sitting around the bar here thinking
about it I mean what is your level of
disappointment or or are you not
disappointed you know that that say new
physics is is very difficult to seem to
reveal in that um you know we really we
the discovery of the Higgs was a
Monumental Discovery but I think you
know physicists expected and promoted
and hyped up a lot more possibilities uh
than were actually discovered and I
think so too with the Dark Matter
searches that my colleagues here at UCSD
and yours in Chicago and elsewhere are
doing have yet failed to really identify
are we looking in the wrong place I
often say you know to look for the to
look for you know your lost Keys you
have to look where the light is but in
this case you know we should you know
perhaps we need to Pivot the way that
we're thinking about re-evaluate the way
that we're thinking about Dark Matter so
just personally you know I'm just a gut
level are you disappointed are you
hopeful are you both how how do you
react to the to the Lacuna that we have
seemingly to identify in terms of what
we previously expected
well yeah of course I'm disappointed
like if you asked me 10 or 15 years ago
I would have given you a very
enthusiastic pitch about how dark
Matter's Discovery is inevitable
um and I would have been happy to take a
bet that we would have discovered the
nature of dark matter by now and I would
have lost that bet
um in fact I did make that stuff like
that and I I lost all but um luckily you
work in a very prestigious private
school
mostly they had to do with honor we even
when there was something else but uh but
yeah I mean lots of us were really
surprised not just about dark matter but
um the lack of
new physics
um being discovered a Large Hadron
Collider surprised a lot of us
um there were some people who who said
you know more pessimistic things but
most of us in the community were pretty
sure that when the Large Hadron Collider
was going to discover maybe super
symmetric particles or something else
that would address what we call a
hierarchy problem or or other things but
there was a lot of optimism even an
expectation that by now we would have
discovered all sorts of new parts
when it comes to dark matter I mean the
arguments we had were based on on how
what kind of particle we thought would
have been produced in the Big Bang and
the right quantity to make up the dark
matter and we kind of used some some
arguments which okay they're not
bulletproof but they were suggestive
saying that the kinds of particles that
would would make up the Dark Matter
would be the sort of particles that we
could build these underground detectors
and go and look for them and we should
have seen them by now and yet they're
not there the experiments have been
awesome like they performed
spectacularly well but no signals have
appeared
so in light of that
um we're kind of thinking in different
ways I think you use this this analogy
before but you know instead of looking
under the lamp posts for our keys we're
getting flashlights out and looking in
different places or finding new ways to
look in different places testing models
and theories that maybe we had thought
of before but weren't our high priority
back then
um but yeah we're we're casting a much
wider net than we used to
um and I guess I'm I'm
still cautiously optimistic that this is
a problem we can solve but
um right now I'm not as optimistic as
about to say the next five years as I
would have been if you asked me 10 years
ago that's fair enough yeah yeah I mean
I do feel like there is a tendency to
kind of over promise and when we do it
in our field too
um uh and as experimentalists of what
we're going to be able to achieve and
and it's not you know uh dishonest it's
really what we're you know it's our goal
it's what we're striving to accomplish
and we talk ourselves into it right you
know yeah the confirmation bias there's
the some cost fallacy I mean people the
funniest thing is people think you know
scientists are you know bias free and
have no prejudices whatsoever you know
but a cursory look at you know we try
yeah we do yeah it's kind of Wishful uh
self-hachiography but but I do think you
know just getting back into the the meat
of the book you know that really spoke
to me was how you really are are weaving
a story that is um by its nature it's
unfinishable in that we we will not have
you know so you let the appetite very
well but we you know at the at the
combination of it I find you know a left
with there's a sense of wonder and you
know what we what we are knowing I think
Archibald John Archibald wheeler said
you know kind of like science is this
island and you expand the island into
this ocean of ignorance and as you do
that the island gets bigger but the
boundary of ignorance gets clear too it
just gets bigger a little bit slower is
a slower power but I think you know the
book
um you know and it's a positive thing
but it's disappointing because it really
shows you know how little we know and
looking back into weinberg's book 40
years ago now and and again yours is so
comparable to in many ways
um
you know on one hand it's depressing but
on the other hand it's kind of exciting
to live in a time you know historians
look back at Copernicus and Galilee oh
they didn't even know about you know
universal gravitation but um but they
were able to describe they weren't
discontent with what they knew they knew
there was probably stuff they didn't
know but it wasn't like as relevant I
think to their daily practice of being a
scientist now we have all these known
unknowns and and really I think your
book highlights these things that we
know are true we know there's a Barry
and Ice imagery we know that there are
neutrinos we know that there's dark
brown we know that there's Dark Energy
we know the universe has evolving but
you know the why questions and I think
that that's a very tough thing to do and
you do it well and and give the reader a
sense of hope but also that the scale of
the challenge is Monumental
um and I wonder you know as
experimentalists we're kind of
singularly focused we're you know we're
designing we're looking at you know
forecasting modeling simulating
systematics as a theorist you know on a
practical level what is your day-to-day
what are you doing what are you thinking
about nowadays I mean the book obviously
takes an enormous heroic amount of
effort what are you devoting your energy
towards now is it exploring deeper the
topics that are at the edge of time or
are is it something completely new and
pivoting yet again
maybe some of each
um I have a personality
that likes to take something really dive
deep into it and then three months later
be done with it and think about
something terribly different
so
um I mean just today
I had a couple of meetings with my
collaborators on a couple of projects so
I'll tell you like what today was like
yeah
um in one of those we're talking about
uh classes of Dark Matter models that
could explain this thing called the
galactic center gamma-ray access this
was a signal I discovered 10 years ago
um and it might be from Dark Matter
particles we don't know yeah and um we
are in a very concrete way working out
which models can explain this data along
with some other data it's a very
concrete very bottom-up very uh almost
pragmatic paper and then the other one
that we're working on different people
different collaborators we are imagining
what the early Universe might have been
like if there'd been an era where the
entire universe was dominated not by
matter and radiation but by black holes
this is kind of the opposite for me this
is the Other Extreme this is uh super
speculative super far field but it turns
out that it leads to a bunch of kind of
cool observational consequences that we
could test and we're working out how
these black holes would have evolved how
they would a creek matter how they would
radiate and the way that Stephen Hawking
described
um what kind of gravitational waves
would be produced we're even considering
that they might have produced a
background and observable background of
gravitons which I mean it's not very
often that we get to use graviton in
real science
um that's almost like a such such a far
such a difficult thing to ever measure
um just for your for your viewers a
graviton would be is the hypothetical
particle that carries
um the effects of gravity through space
and time the quantized version of that
and you know most businesses think that
this thing probably exists but you know
it's virtually impossible to ever
measure one so this is this is pretty
far afield stuff but um he said that
about the cosmic neutrino background
in the book did I say that no no I'm
joking I'm saying they said it was
impossible to detect the cup uh they did
okay and it still is well what we can we
can see it's that we can detect it in
the CMB right well you know that of
course but yeah to detect those particle
wreck detection right yes when I was a
grad student I made a bet with one of
the other grad students I went to a
summer school with that in 50 years we
would detect the neutrinos and the
calcium neutrino background
can we make a bet you know I got some
action I I got to get in on this Hooper
action offer me one man I'm gonna put my
kids into grad school you know
you have to make a lot of Bets with me
to do that it's not a lot of money
especially UC
oh great well um uh were you were you
done with that uh particular story uh
Dan or do you want to follow up on that
or no no that that's that's where I
wanted to get okay great so I know
you're super busy you've got book tours
um and I really appreciative of your
time I want to close with a question
that I ask all people we've had artists
poets science fiction authors
um you know we have a great tradition
here at the Arthur colleagues Arthur C
Clarke Center for human imagination uh
in terms of the uh amount and and
prolific nature of the artist and and
authors and scientists that we work with
I I always like to ask these uh visitors
on the podcast guests on the podcast the
same question I want to ask it to you
now and that has to do with the nature
of imagination of human imagination and
we hear a lot and you've you know
tangentially thought about this You Know
spoken about this online at least on
Twitter I've seen but you know the
notion of Consciousness the notion of
imagination the notion of creativity are
those things that you know someone like
you uh who's who's breached you know
many different fields and unified them
together in writing and teaching and in
scientific creativity can you teach
those things in your opinion do you feel
and if so how how do you go about
curating cultivating the next generation
of you know Renaissance men and women uh
if it's even possible in your opinion so
first do you think it's possible and
second you know if so how
so let's separate the break the question
into marks the so I'm sure that it is in
principle teachable or honorable
um I see no reason why it wouldn't be
it's it's a task like any other and
um
I'm convinced the human brain is just a
very sophisticated and complex machine
um if you can if the human brain can do
it then you can teach or or build a
machine that can do it but therefore our
brains can get better at it
but B I just because I think I'm
confident in principle can be done I
don't know how to go about doing it
effectively
um I have not found like with the grad
students I could buy for example that I
can be meaningful impact on their like
personality or or kind of way that they
approach research I can teach them
scientific facts I can teach them how to
write paper more clear I can do things
like this but I can't teach them to come
up with new and creative ideas sometimes
it happens sometimes they just end up
being able to do that and sometimes they
don't
um but I haven't personally been able to
find any special sauce that enables me
to do that
um maybe somebody who knows a lot more
about teaching which or psychology for
that matter could but
um but not me yeah if you have any tips
I'll gladly take them well I always I
always find it ironic that you know as
professors as you know basically get
thrown in front of you know a bunch of
students and they never really teach us
how to teach they never teach us about
the process of learning and recently I
started becoming on the process of
becoming a flight instructor uh to you
know supplement the uh the modest income
I get here at the State University at
these you know universities here in
California I'm just kidding I'm
compensated fairly and I find it very
interesting and almost ironic that the
federal government spends so much more
time you know imagine an organization
like the IRS you know that has a booklet
and huge huge booklet about the
psychology of pedagogy and you know the
Maslow's hierarchy of needs and all
sorts of things like I never knew as you
know my 16 years of being a professor
never once now maybe I missed out on I
know we have resources here I know you
have resources there but um but it's
certainly not the case that that seems
to be emphasized at least in the
promotion process and the you know
you're really kind of gauge them in your
papers your grad students your
mentorship on a one-on-one level but not
really on the gross process of as a
gross motor skill so to speak of of
pedagogy so
um I don't have any you know Secret
Sauce there although I am learning a
little bit about that and hope maybe I
can report back you know once I get my
first couple of students uh that Solo in
an airplane that might be scary to some
people out there thinking about that
um well I want to be conscious of your
time I really appreciate you joining us
here on into the impossible a podcast of
the Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination at UC San Diego and uh just
uh give you a chance to do uh you know a
couple of plugs the the plug zone is
open for you to help people out in uh on
the internet where they can find you and
where you're going to be in in uh in
three-dimensional world in the next
couple weeks and and how to follow you
thank you
so uh you can
I handles uh Dan Hooper Astro
um I'm going to be finishing up this
part of my book tour this week and uh
next week I think it's on Thursday I'll
be at the Seminary Co-op bookstore in
Chicago
um and then there's some other things uh
in 2020 scheduled
um and I'd just encourage everybody to
check out the book at the Edge of Time
exploring the mysteries of our universes
for seconds and let me know what you
think
um I'm easy to find on the internet so I
I welcome
all all constructive uh criticism or
comets
great and yeah Compliments are are never
to be turned away well then thank you so
much uh both for your conversation and
your uh wonderful new book uh and I
definitely encourage folks to look for
it I will leave the links to it and to
you and the description uh for the
podcast and the YouTube video so thank
you so much for joining us Dan enjoy the
rest of your tour
thanks Brian I really appreciate it
thanks for that chance
[Music]
the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is that it will be absolutely
fantastic
down one
[Music]